[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
albert breer one of my favorite nfl
insiders nfl reporter league content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback
and i know that albert lives vicariously
through us the traeger grills are fired
up albert
the grilled chicago dogs chili cheese
dogs today bacon wrapped hot dogs
and tater tots that's how we do it here
on the dan patrick show
yeah not bad i like i i feel like i
almost insulted pearl off when i texted
him and i guess that they were sloppy
joes
you guys are way way beyond that oh yeah
oh yeah yeah you should come in on a
friday meet friday
come on down you guys aren't too far so
maybe i'll make the trip that'd be nice
all right we've been talking about this
tom brady situation that
the report is that he played on a uh
fully torn
mcl the entire season what
what are gamblers so what information
should they be
getting here like would is the nfl going
to go after tampa bay with this
information that just come out
that's a fair question because i think
we've always known the injury reports
have related to gambling right like i
don't think that's been a big secret
although the nfl could never actually
say that over the last 30 40 years
however long it's been since they've
done that
but i do think that now that it's out in
the open a little bit more and
like the league is more free to speak
about this stuff
and because they're going to be doing
partnerships
with casinos um i think i i i
might be mistaken about this i think a
couple teams already have those like the
caesars
partnerships and everything else you
know maybe they're going to get a little
more serious about it because in the
past i think they've worked with teams
on these things
and tried to make sure that at least
competitively it was equitable
from team to team but now that you're
actually
you know out in the open doing
partnerships with gambling companies
and maybe there will be a little bit of
a shift um it'll be interesting to see
because i do know
and i can tell you this you know flat
out dan like brady doesn't like his
injuries being on that report like he
would do
when he was in new england do whatever
it took to make sure that those injuries
wouldn't be on the report and
um you know played with ligament damage
in his hand in 2013 played with a
separated shoulder in 2011
he's played through a lot of stuff and i
know it was always a priority of his to
keep
that stuff off the injury report and not
even like as a team competitive thing
but just to prevent players from going
after parts of his bodies that were
banged up and
i understand that but is brady keeping
that from the patriots or the patriots
keeping that from
the world and that's what's so
interesting about it too dan is like you
look at it and like
brady's almost got his own ecosystem so
like you know where most teams like with
most players it's like the team's
trainers the team's doctors are going to
know everything
brady sort of got his own like setup you
know with alex guerrero and all the
different people that he works with
so he's one of the few players where
it's plausible
that like maybe they did hide it from
the team and maybe
and look like i'm just playing devil's
advocate here but if you're brady
and your priority is to keep it off the
injury report
maybe it makes sense for you to say alex
and i are going to keep this to
ourselves
and we're not going to get the bucks in
trouble we're just going to keep it from
them
i think it's he's one of the few players
where it's actually plausible
that maybe the trainers and the doctors
had a little less knowledge of the
injury than you might think
i i just had a uh a tweet from one of
our listeners john and georgia
exactly why do bettors have a right to
know seriously
where does this right come from
professional sports somehow has an
obligation to mitigate a better's risk
question mark really
why how is that
uh like it goes back like to like when i
was a kid so i don't know if i can even
properly answer that
dan you might have better insight on it
than me i
i would say well they don't want insider
trading you don't want to have
somebody tell somebody and it could
really let let's say you don't know
patrick mahomes is going to play
right and you decide to jump on you know
the uh chargers playing kansas city
because mahomes you know
is not going to play that's what they're
trying to avoid
or he's going to play but he's got an
injured toe and his he's really
like they don't want the money to move
based on you know somebody like me
deciding okay i've got the injury
information now
i'm gonna commodify it right yeah like
and i'm gonna turn into something that i
can sell
yes that makes sense like that part
makes sense where they wouldn't want
that
explain to me what's going on with
desean watson from the league's
perspective
can they put him on the commissioner's
exempt list they can do what they want
um i i can tell you this and you know
they went through this a couple years
ago with tyree kill
um and i i remember the question at the
time was why weren't they putting them
on the commissioner's exempt list over
the course of the spring and i think
if i remember right the chiefs actually
came to an agreement with tyrique to
stay away
from their spring workouts because they
just wanted to let the legal situation
play out
um you know i the the league's stance on
these things is
they won't do it until they have to and
what's interesting is because the fine
system has changed and because you can't
forgive training camp fines anymore
uh that juncture in the calendar might
come sooner now it might be the start of
training camp for them and so
i think what everybody's waiting for is
the legal situation to play out
and i think based on the way some of
these things have gone over the last few
years
really over the last 10 years i don't
know if the league wants to
come down with any sort of ruling
without there being legal clarity
on how all this is going to play out and
so
i think my sense is the league would
probably try to kick the can
down the road as long as the legal
situation is still playing out
and the way they kick the can down the
road dan is that exempt list right like
they put the player on paid leave and
they basically push pause on the whole
thing
and they've been able to push pause in
the whole thing because desean didn't
show up in the spring
right so it wasn't an issue but now with
the
training camp reporting date being
whatever it is a week and a half two
weeks away
they uh you know you would think that
they would be they would have to make a
decision on whether or not to put them
on the exempt list unless
you know watson's lawyers um can find a
way to reach a settlement um between now
and
july 27th but then the league is
probably going to discipline
deshaun watson i'm guessing right yeah i
mean i don't think
i mean i've been asked a lot like will
he play in 2021
um i think there's a possibility and
there's a good chance he plays in 2021 i
do not think he'll be playing for
any team in in week one um so i think
that
this and this is regardless of
what happens in court um because you
know i think it's
gotten to the point where the
commissioner can say
you put yourself in a bad spot and in
turn that put the league in a bad spot
and so you you brought
you brought negative publicity to the
nfl which is basically
the grounds for suspending ben
roethlisberger in 2010
and so i think you know ben
roethlisberger if there's a settlement i
think
the ben roethlisberger case becomes the
precedent
and they say all right like we're gonna
take you off the field for eight games
and if you hit certain conditions it
goes down to six or six games and with
certain conditions it goes down to four
i think that's probably what we're
looking at and then once you have that
clarity then i think we can start to
talk about
you know when is he going to be traded
are you more curious about desean watson
over the next couple of weeks or aaron
rodgers
i would say aaron rodgers just because
like i think that there's a good chance
there's a decent chance
that some sort of arrangement is worked
out where if
we don't have clarity in the legal
situation like
the league is gonna find a way to make
it so deshawn watson doesn't show up in
houston because
i don't think anybody wants what would
happen if he showed up there
right like i don't think the league
wants it i don't think deshawn wants it
i don't think the texans want it right
um whereas with rogers there's a hard
date
he's july 27th he shows up he doesn't
yeah like to me like that's the most
interesting one
and i think there's a much better chance
that rogers plays for the packers in
2021 then
watson plays for the texans in 2021
uh but there's obviously a lot that
needs to be worked out
and you know like i think a lot of what
needs to be worked out is going to come
down to can you fix the communication
issue
at least temporarily so the packers who
believe they have a championship roster
right now
can have their quarterback back in the
short term in the very least
what happens on the 27th with aaron
rodgers explain
the financial aspect of that let's say
he doesn't show up
if he doesn't show up then they can
start finding him fifty thousand dollars
they're
required to start finding him unless
there's some sort of extenuating
circumstance
they're required to start finding him
fifty thousand dollars a day
um if he misses pre-season games he gets
docked more
and the difference this year um versus
what it was
two years ago and before that is that
those fines cannot be forgiven
and teams in general would almost
routinely
forgive these fines like you remember
aaron donald like there were i think it
was
two full training camps he missed right
paid zero for that right like
he came in the rams forgave all the
fines like no problem and
that was sort of part of the impetus for
the owners saying we're sick of this
like teams aren't adhering to this we
can't really use this as a hammer
and so certain owners said like let's
put it in the cba that you can't forgive
the fines now
so we all have a very real hammer here
and so now like the packers are in this
spot where it's like
or the packers and rogers are in this
spot where if he misses days of camp
they have to find him and they can't go
back and and and and forgive those fines
now
there are obviously things you can do
like you could build that money back
into a contract extension right like so
there are things that you can do but it
definitely i think
kind of casts a different light on on
holdouts and that's why i think like
what we're gonna see with some of these
and the rogers is separate for it like
stefan gilmore for example with the
patriots
i wouldn't be surprised if stefan
gilmore shows up on july 27th
and then says that torn quad i had last
year not ready
and it's not going to be ready for a
little while you know so it's not going
to be ready to
that's probably a new contract is ready
right right it's like the
instead of a holdout it's a hold in you
know is uh is cam newton
still the starter in new england so like
i i would say the most the way new
england's program is set up they'll tell
you
the spring is set up to focus on
fundamentals on teaching
and on conditioning that said
what a rookie can accomplish in the
spring is he can set up a competition
for the summer
and that's what they'll all tell you is
they'll say a rookie can't win a job
in the spring but he can at the very
least put himself in the mix
and from everything that i heard over
the last three months
mac jones did that so mac jones has
created a situation where he can compete
for the job
in july and august now is
bill belichick going to be comfortable
going with a rookie quarterback in week
one
would he be comfortable putting mac
jones into the spotlight in week four
where tom brady is going to be coming
back into foxborough
which would be a big spot you know for
uh for a rookie quarterback i don't care
how prepared you are to be in the nfl
and mack jones is prepared for the nfl
um you know that's an open question but
i do think
you know and you know again like just
based on everything that i've heard
that mac jones did enough from a
learning standpoint and from an
on-field performance standpoint in the
spring to set up a competition
um starting in late july and i think at
the very least
it's gonna look like a competition when
we get to training camp
which la team is more interesting
that's a great question i
i i'm on the matthew stafford bandwagon
dan
like i i i think like
i think the general public has a much
like a much lower opinion of him than
people in football have
like i think if you talk to scouts if
you talk to coaches they think this guy
is outstanding
like and the idea of putting him in sean
mcvay's offense and we can argue about
like the way the rams are set up and how
they don't have any first-round picks
until five years from now
now and all that different stuff but the
idea of sean mcvay
with matthew stafford right now today
um throwing to robert woods and cooper
cup and having cam akers behind him
and you know on the other side defense
with aaron donald jaylen ramsey i think
it's fascinating
um and so like i wouldn't be surprised
that matthew stafford is the mvp of the
league
and um so i would i would give the
slight edge to the rams but
like what brandon staley is walking into
with the chargers
is awfully interesting too so i think
you know the first year
of that stadium actually able to have
fans in it and all the rest of it and
the super bowl being there
now i think both those teams have a
chance to be really really good the rams
a super bowl contender
i don't think the chargers are quite
there yet but there's talent on that
roster dan
you know i mean it's not just justin
herbert it's
you know mike williams and and joey bosa
and derwin james and
and young guys like kenneth murray like
that's a
it's a really good team and so i'd say
rams legitimate super bowl aspirations
chargers i think i think the chargers
may be more of a pain in the ass
for the chiefs than anyone else in their
division
put it that way open invitation join us
on a meet friday there albert okay
i'm gonna try to make it down there i
think it's about a two hour drive maybe
when i'm on my way to new york uh
in the fall uh how far are you guys from
the train station pretty close right yep
pretty close we can pick you up in fact
you can even
you can even make a request to what you
want on the menu there you go
there you go i'm a big smoker guy too so
i'm gonna
i gotta i gotta hit up pearl off and
make sure he sends me pictures of
whatever comes out of
all that later today thank you albert as
always have a great weekend
all right thanks dan have a good one
that's albert breer senior nfl reporter
monday morning quarterback